hi I'm Jessica Clemens and welcome back
to New rockstars Guardians of the
Galaxy's holiday special definitely put
me in my feelings because mantis of
Peter are the only family they got left
and it makes me really sad and I love
sappy Christmas movies with Danny Elfman
music included it's just I also like
learning that nebula stays thieving
because you guys know I'm a thief you
guys know I like to steal things all the
time don't invite me over to your houses
for Christmas she got rocky buckets
prosthetic arm and as we all remember he
really wanted that arm pretty badly in
Infinity War the gift that just keeps on
giving you know severed limbs stolen
from your counterparts either way how in
the hell did she get this arm I have my
theories and we'll go through it right
now with a quick timeline discussion and
Bucky's unfortunate armley demise Army
demise Army demise and brought his
timeline order here we go after losing
his arm in 45 Bucky gained an arm by
Hydra we learned that during the Korean
war in 51 Isaiah Bradley took half of
his arm into fighting goyang assuming it
was fixed later in 91 he killed the
Starks with the same arm we've been
seeing with the red star that's when
it's destroyed by Tony during the fight
in Civil War then he decides to go to
wakanda until they can solve his
brainwashing in wakanda they gave him a
vibranium arm the same one allegedly in
the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special he still had the arm during
Falcon in the Winter Soldier as well
though we learned you can detach the arm
with a lock safe because I love the
wakandans doing this the two arms don't
look the same to me and maybe that's
just me you guys because I'm No Light
expert does it look like I know science
but we see the red green blue lights
Illuminating off the arm giving it a
yellowish lighter bluish finish
comparing that to the arm from the
Thunderbolts poster it's not the same
even in broad daylight it doesn't look
the same I looked up images of Bucky
even surrounded by vibrant lights during
Falcon and the Winter Soldier and the
light doesn't bounce off the same and
his hand has a clear indent of yellow
lastly the lion Ridge is near the
shoulder and bicep don't have the same
arching during this fight scene from the
Falcon and lunar Soldier where it's in
the exact same shape and position but I
think this is crazy good arm you know I
just it is just really heavy it might
have similar fighting durability because
I think this arm was created by nebula
hear me out we know Thanos would make
Gamora and nebula fight and every time
nebula lost she'd lose a piece of
herself to Machinery I know very tragic
but we also see her in different
instances repairing herself after
detaching herself from her hand and
Guardians of Galaxy 1 she simply
replaced it in volume 2. our girl's
Nifty I could see her easily creating a
piece for Rocket like this let's just
assume that nebula did steal Bucky's
actual physical arm when would she have
done it this takes place after Thor love
and thunder taking into account that
Groot is no longer an angsty teen look
at my boys growing up she could one have
stolen between them leaving indigar and
appearing at nowhere hey you've probably
seen me talk about raycon earbuds
they're super comfortable have premium
sound and up to 54 hours of battery life
and I have one
right here did you see that so now that
it's the holidays I'm looking for gifts
I'm sharing the love and getting raycons
for maybe just just everybody they
started half the price of other premium
audio Brands plus raycon makes it easy
with the holiday gift guides for
everyone in your life whether it's your
Fitness obsessed brother your podcast
obsessed father or your co-worker who
should really be listening to music on
their headphones Tommy I'm talking to
you get 30 off when you buy one of
raycon's holiday bundles raycons are
sleek and stylish and come in a range of
colors that match your style these ones
are black and I only wear black because
I only wear black clothes to work out at
the gym I don't want you to see my sweat
raycons raycon earbuds are currently
available in stores like Kohl's or
Walmart but you're always going to get
the best deals when you use the special
link buy recon.com me Rockstars it's
going to be below it's probably right
here the raycon website also offers buy
now pay later options so you can get a
pair of raycons now and pay what is more
convenient for you I literally use those
options all the time click the link in
the description box go to buy raycon.com
new rockstars or save even bigger and
get 30 off raycons exclusive holiday
bundles there will also be different
deals coming throughout the season and
I'll try to keep the description box
updated with the latest offers but just
so you know you can always go to buy
raycon.com new rockstars to get the best
deals available on raycon
we don't know where the Guardians went
after leaving Thor and Thor 11 thunder
so if they address some of the distress
calls they receive may be winding up on
Earth she could have stolen Bucky's arm
there if they cross paths at the
beginning of the holiday special nebula
also mentions ever since buying nowhere
from The Collector that's a big thing
that's big news they're helping rebuild
nowhere seeing as most of it was
destroyed in the first Guardians movie
then later in Infinity War we know the
collector survived but we didn't really
see his body he mentioned in an
interview yeah my character is still
alive and now we officially know so they
must have purchased it off The Collector
just to help the planet grow again she
might have found remnants of what the
collector Left Behind one of that being
Bucky's arm in this case I don't think
it's his current actual physical arm
though but maybe another arm created for
him that was taken to the collector by
someone who might have stole it from
Hydra Theory number two nebula was on
Earth mainly Avengers campus during end
game because rocket and her didn't snap
so during that time rocket probably told
her how badly he wanted Bucky's arm not
to be a horrible person I mean truly not
horrible maybe I'm just a gruesome
person but maybe just maybe she kind of
used the blueprints from her dead pass
up that she killed an endgame to make
that that arm I really hope not because
that's so dark but maybe Tony Stark made
something similar to fight Bucky during
his brainwash days and it was sitting at
Avengers campus and nebula took it for
herself later giving it to Rocket if it
was a Tony Stark original based arm it
could also give reason to what happens
to Tony's assets now that he's dead some
were kept by Stark industry some was
taken by the dodc and so forth so maybe
someone stole and sold this item to the
collector like my theory above with
Hydra something like that could make its
way through the Galaxy ending in
nebula's pocket though that seems like a
very wild Theory I know they technically
weren't even planning on celebrating
Christmas anyway so these gifts were
either found made in a rush or just
sitting around let me know what you
think in the comics if nebula really did
steal the arm or it's a fake regardless
I love this and I love that people
remember the weird requests that rocket
has follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at Lulu underscore Clemons follow new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
from our breakdowns with everything you
love and before you go remember that the
break room and new rockstars are
performing at La Comic-Con December 4th
at 10 30 a.m come check us out we have
it down in the description look on our
our socials thanks for watching and I
call dibs on Falcons wings next
[Music]